when we got in here before we were
rolling
we talked about William Shatner and he
just turned 92 years old yeah and
um you said you just had dinner with him
last night oh Saturday or Saturday night
are you close friends with William we're
friends I do call him bill yeah you
don't call him chat no no uh there is a
famous story however of you know he
famously or not so famously to to people
who don't know theater but he one of his
big hits on Broadway when he was a young
man was a shot in the dark which later
became a Peter Sellers film he didn't
play that role it was completely
Rewritten but uh it was Bill and Walter
Matthau and apparently math out told me
this story that uh Judy Holliday came
back afterwards and she said this guy
Shatner is is his name in the past tense
it's funny because I do say that to my
friends I'm gonna go take a Bill Shatner
and you know I don't think he'd
appreciate it no I doubt it but no uh
yeah I'm friends with Bill and and uh
you call him
uh if I need to or a text I have I have
done yeah yeah and what would you and
Bill text about well one time uh
somebody
somebody somebody tweeted me privately
that uh he had can't he had what do you
call it when he he blocked them and uh
and they were really upset about it and
I'm so sorry I but I can't I don't know
what to do how do I apologize for you I
said look don't worry about it he
probably doesn't write those things
anyway or have anything to do with it
and uh and then I get this this text
from him or uh and it said not from him
uh it wasn't attacked it was a direct
message saying what in the hell is wrong
with you why would you say something
like that and I thought oh my God if I
overstep so I called him and uh he
happened to be in and he came to the
phone I said Bill I'm so sorry I you
know I didn't realize that was I was
crossing the line with that and he said
what are you talking about and I said
and he didn't know anything about it oh
my God so someone writing for him yeah
but you know what's he like I mean when
you're hanging out and having dinner
with him I didn't even think I was gonna
ask you this question until you brought
up dinner with him but like is he fun
I'm sure he has endless stories endless
and but he's also one of the most
well-read people oh yeah ever me I go to
cons and his face is buried in a book
always every time always and and uh he's
so knowledgeable he really is and he's
so interested in the world I think
that's why he's who he is now he's uh
his energy is unbelievable uh he has way
more energy than I do me too and uh he's
uh he's just a voracious reader he's
interested in all sorts of subjects
anything about uh you know space space
but the world uh trees bees Birds he'll
read books about them I mean he's just a
fascinating guy do you like having a
friend who knows everything